game developer Peter Molyneux today  announced his retirement on his Twitter  fake we too were shocked when hearing  the news but as it turns out Peter was  simply hacked goldis will be taken down  from the steam store with immediate  effect thank you to all those involved  the first of these fake tweets read this  is also the time we would like to  announce my retirement from the games  industry it has been a long journey for  me thank you gamespot reached out to  Molly news company 22cans and they  confirmed his account was hacked and his  tweets are untrue oddly the fall suites  remain online at least for now the 56  year-old Molly new has been a game  developer for more than three decades  having worked on Dungeon Keeper  syndicate populous fable and most  recently goddess this is Alexa ray keep  it at gamespot for your daily gaming  coverage